[Music]
with the final two installments of the
fast and furious franchise currently
getting tuned up in universal's garage
there are high hopes that the last
chapter in the story all about family
will have everyone available involved
well almost everyone four time faster
dwayne johnson confirmed that he was
done with the franchise earlier this
year he notoriously had behind the
scenes issues with the head of the tire
screeching heights gang vin diesel and
the two haven't worked together if you
can even call it that since the fate of
the furious since then it's been a war
of the worlds between the two hollywood
heavyweights they'll often jab at each
other across social media and it's
abundantly clear there's no love lost
between the two action stars the big
screen spats that seem to have lasted
four years has been stitched together
with stories from both parties involved
but one in particular was something even
johnson had to laugh at speaking to usa
today in 2017 diesel reflected on his
former work colleague and the supposed
extended gun to help johnson diesel said
i protect the franchise i protect
everybody including dwayne dwayne has
only got one vin in his life dwayne
johnson only has one big brother in this
film world and that's me diesel went on
to claim that he paved the way for
johnson's rise to superstardom and while
the accuracy of that statement is
debatable it does come across as a way
to offer a backhanded compliment to the
star of red notice and san andreas
johnson eventually learned of diesel's
comments and his response to them
suggests that they are still driving on
different sides of the street you want
to make this family whole again
speaking to vanity fair this year
johnson spoke on a myriad of topics he's
had one of the most meteoric rises
through hollywood's hierarchy so much so
that he's even contemplating a run for
president of the united states while a
decent percentage of americans seem open
to the idea johnson has taken time to
dampen that enthusiasm stating i may
have some decent leadership qualities
but that doesn't necessarily make me a
great presidential candidate that's
where i am today of course given
diesel's recent comments referring to
johnson as a little brother the feud was
bound to make an appearance during his
vanity fair interview naturally johnson
had a different viewpoint entirely from
his former coaster diesel has referred
to johnson as hollywood's second
multicultural megastar but the rock
seemed untouched by the statement and
his mention of being diesel's little
brother johnson said i have one big
brother and it's my half brother and
that's it with such opposing views the
chances of getting these two back
together to chest bump and make up seems
unlikely even diesel's instagram post
asking his former co-star to get back
behind the wheel didn't get a reaction
from johnson but he does have a fairly
busy schedule not only is he set on
joining the dc universe as a star of
black adam but is also set to be
returning as hobbs opposite jason
statham's owen shaw in a sequel to their
2019 spin-off hobbs and shore in that
sense fans like miss johnson can be
happy to be getting the rock back in
that world if only by an alternative
route there may not be any chance of
reconciliation between johnson and
diesel but that doesn't mean they can't
laugh at the situation later in the
vanity fair interview when johnson's
reminded of what diesel said he
elaborated you know i'll tell you this
one part of me feels like there's no way
i would dignify any of that bullsh with
an answer but here's the truth i've been
around the block a lot of times unlike
him i did not come from the world of
theater and you know i came up
differently and was raised differently
johnson continued and i came from a
completely different culture and
environment and i go into every project
giving it my all and if i feel that
there's some things that need to be
squared away and handled and taken care
of then i do it and it's just that
simple so when i read that just like
everybody else i left i laughed hard we
all laughed
he's no friend
i don't have friends
i got family as diesel said initially
they're both alphas and there just
wasn't enough room on that set for the
two of them to get along still it would
make fast and furious fans delighted to
see the two share the screen once again
it would certainly be a way to make the
fast and furious franchise go out with a
bang of course considering that f9 made
a tidy box office some worldwide without
the benefit of johnson's star power
maybe this series will shift gears just
fine
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you